how does an atomic weapon work how does
a hydrogen bomb work asking for a friend
yeah
yeah so um added sort what it had what
you do is you very quickly put together
enough of these materials that can
undergo fission with room temperature
neutrons and you put them together fast
enough that what happens is that this
process can essentially grow
mathematically like very fast and so
this releases large amounts of energy so
that's the underlying reason that it
works so you've heard of a fusion weapon
so this is interesting is that it is it
but it's dislike Fusion Energy in the
sense that what happens is that you're
using
Fusion reactions to but it's simply it
increases the gain actually of the
weapon rather than
um it's it's not a pure at its heart
it's still a fission weapon you're just
using Fusion reactions as a sort of
intermediate Catalyst basically to get
even more energy out of it
but it's not directly applicable to to
be used in an energy source does it
terrify you just again to step back at
the philosophical that humans have been
able to use physics and
uh engineering to create such powerful
weapons
I wouldn't say terrify I mean we should
be
this is the this is the progress of
human every time that we've gone access
you talk again you know the day the
universe changed those really changed
when we got access to new kinds of
energy sources but every time you get
acts and typically what this meant was
you get access to more intense energy
right that's and that's what that was
and so the ability to move from burning
wood to using coal to using gasoline and
petrol and then finally to use this is
that is that both the potency and the
consequences are elevated around those
things it's just like you said the the
way that Fusion nuclear fusion would
change the world
I don't think unless we think really
deeply we'll be able to anticipate some
of the things we can create there's
going to be a lot of amazing stuff but
then that amazing stuff is going to
enable more amazing stuff and more
unfortunately or uh depending how you
see on it more powerful weapons well
yeah but see that's the thing Fusion
breaks that Trend in the following way
so one of them so Fusion doesn't work on
a chain reaction
there's no Chain Reaction zero so this
means it cannot physically exponentiate
away on you because it works and
actually this is why Star by the way we
know this already is why stars are so
stable why most stars and suns are so
stable it's because they are regulated
through their own temperature and their
Heating
because what's happening is not that
there's some probability of this
exponentiating away is that the energy
that's being released by Fusion
basically is keeping the fire hot
and these tend to be you know and when
it comes down to thermodynamics and
things like this there's a reason for
example it's pretty easy to keep of
constant temperature like in an oven and
things like this it's the same thing
infusion so this is actually one of the
features that I would argue Fusion
breaks the breaks the trend of this is
that it's it has more energy intensity
than than fission on on paper but it
actually does not have the consequences
of control and sort of Rapid Release of
the energy because it's actually it the
physical system just doesn't want to do
that yeah we're gonna have to look
elsewhere for the weapons with which we
fight World War III
fair enough